i'm erena sinakoje i'm an author in my
humble opinion black joy should be
embedded within the fabric of our
culture and shouldn't just be temporary
or fleeting
[Music]
so black joy is expanding the notion of
what black arts history is and it's it's
contributing to the culture it's shaping
what conversations we have it's it's
being completely free and unencumbered
in terms of ideas and having absolute
agency and i think being your most
authentic self because sometimes it can
be difficult um operating within the
western structure in terms of how we
express ourselves as artists and how we
celebrate our culture if i were to give
concrete examples of what black joy
means to me i would say it's reading a
june jordan poem it's watching a barry
jenkins film it's listening to a fella
cootie record on a hot day it's looking
at an image of a basquiat exhibition all
of these things represent black artistry
and black innovation and the complete
freedom and joy that i think is
important as an artist there's so much
happening that signifies black joy at
the moment we're seeing our stories
filter into the mainstream and finally
this idea of whose story is valuable is
coming to the forefront and black
stories are taking precedence not only
coming to the forefront but shaping
cultural narratives and having a really
huge impact so if we look at for example
black panther i would say that that's a
huge cultural moment in terms of black
joy and just the ripple effects it had
globally it shattered every preconceived
notion or myth about whether black
stories are valuable whether they
translate into the mainstream whether
they're too niche your audiences will go
and see them you know here we have a
film about an imagined african kingdom
that celebrates
black innovation and black culture and
authenticity but told using an
afrofuturist aesthetic and it just made
people sit up and take notice
i think the issue for me is that very
much what's happened a lot of the time
for a long time is black trauma has been
something that's been at the forefront
so problematic areas and knife crime and
you know
what that does in the long term i think
is that it creates
a warped sense of
what black culture is so we don't see
enough of black achievement and black
celebration what you get is this idea of
a community being majorly problematic
and there are problems in any community
so
now more than ever with these stories
coming out it's just a great counter
because it shows that that's not all we
are
i think our cultural gatekeepers need to
be more open-minded need to feed
themselves more and read more and listen
more and and create spaces to talk to
people from those communities and from
the black community in particular and i
think that will shape and change things
so it's just about being more open being
more empathetic
listening
and thinking about not just
seeing yourself reflected but other
audiences so if you're somebody in a
position of power say for example you
know you're a commissioning editor or a
producer look around you who's at the
table what do they look like if they all
just look like you then that's an issue
thinking really imaginatively and
creatively and wanting to be very very
experimental in terms of how i approach
what i do so again to counter some of
the negative ideas or stories around
black culture so thinking about
celebrating what we've achieved so for
example my debut novel part of it was
set in the billing kingdom
and my family are fond bringing so it
was about reclaiming a lost heritage a
kind of lost legacy
and how fantastic it was to know about
this kingdom to know about the level of
art and history we need to think more
imaginatively about what the fullness of
blackness is and that you know it's
complicated and nuanced and really
interesting and to mind that and present
that to the forefront
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bell to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon